welcome back to the most dramatic
episode of any show ever
let's do this
we are live streaming for an exclusive
announcement
check this out it looks like Freddy is
proposing to Carly have you had been
here you would have laughed and laughed
or made the face you're making right now
Freddie and pearl are thriving but what
about Freddy and Carly I'd say I'm good
for someone who recently realized she
has feelings for her best friend but he
wants to focus on her friendship which
she totally agrees is the right cough
I regret walking into this energy
oh I think I know what's going on you're
smashing no Freddy has a girlfriend oh
so it's a love triangle there is no
triangle there's a love line between
Freddy and pearl he and I are a squiggle
we're gonna win an Emmy
classic Carly
now let's do a silly one
no matter what awkward phase of Carly
Freddy them we're in I am always going
to be there for you you two are obsessed
with each other
[Music]
damn I missed
Pearl's right
you're the person who I can always count
on
is this really happening it took us long
enough
[Applause]
I want what they have do you not really
[Music]